bonjour patrick l'allemand merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation sur arte france
ce matin comment est-ce que vous
réagissez à sers confinement à la
réunion et en martinique bonne mauvaise
solution attend trop tardif
non je pense que la décision qui a été
prise est tout à fait adapté nous
connaissons pas ici une situation aussi
dramatique dans les antilles françaises
mais néanmoins il vaut mieux aujourd'hui
prendre les bonnes mesures pour faire en
sorte que la dissémination du comique 19
à la réunion marque un coup d'arrêt afin
de permettre à notre société
réunionnaise de reprendre une vie tout à
fait normale dans l'est dans les
semaines à venir des transferts de
patients vers les hôpitaux de paris ont
lu aujourd'hui depuis la martinique
c'est quelque chose que vous connaissez
comment ça se passe exactement dans la
zone océan indien
pendant la juste cassé dernier à ces dix
mois on a dû faire des transferts
surtout entre l'île de mayotte et la
réunion
et il ya eu un seul transfert aérien
entre saint denis de la réunion et paris
mais actuellement l'agencé de la santé a
mobilisé le centre hospitalier
universitaire pour augmenter le nombre
de lits est actuellement ce nombre est
encore suffisant pour subvenir aux
besoins des patients qui ont besoin
d'une réanimation
le préfet de guadeloupe à parler d'un
pic épidémique à venir d'une violence et
d'une brutalité que l'on n'avait pas vu
jusqu'ici en guadeloupe c'est quelque
chose que vous ressentez aussi à la
réunion l'intervention par exemple de
l'armée pour un hôpital de campagne
comme en martinique ça pourrait aider on
parle de 40 soignants et logisticiens
qui vont être déployés à fort-de-france
et ben effectivement on connaît depuis
trois semaines une augmentation
significative du nombre de cas positifs
à la réunion et justement l'arrivée de
ces deux ce confinement devrait
permettre de limiter l'extension de
cette épidémie à la réunion concernant
l'apport éventuel des deux structures
militaires c'est possible mais dans
l'état actuel de notre capacité
sanitaires à la réunion s'est pas encore
nécessaire le premier ministre jean
castex a évoqué cette semaine une
situation je cite dramatique dont de
nombreux
territoires d'outre-mer il a dit des
territoires d'outre-mer rétif à la
vaccination votre réaction les
réunionnais ou encore les martiniquais
voir les guadeloupéens sont plus
réticents que les habitants des
métropoles
si on se base uniquement sur les
chiffres c'est vrai que le taux de
vaccination de la population à la
réunion est légèrement en deçà de celle
qui existe actuellement sur le continent
néanmoins on note depuis quelques et
puis un jour depuis les propos du
président de la république une
augmentation significative des personnes
qui veulent se faire vacciner et je
pense que la sortie du texte le 9 août
devrait donner encore un nouveau élan à
aux personnes qui aujourd'hui se disent
on le fera mais si la loi nous y oblige
donc je pense que pour l'instant on
vaccine mieux s'y attaquer sonné et je
pense qu'après le 9 août
il est très probable que nous avons nous
ayons une augmentation significative du
taux de vaccinés à l'arrivée vous avez
dit tout à l'heure vous étiez plutôt
favorables à ces reconduites mans à la
réunion à la martinique
mais toutes ces mesures avec également
le couvre-feu en guadeloupe ou encore à
saint martin et à saint barthélémy dans
les antilles tout ça ce que ça va pas
pénaliser un secteur touristique
primordial pour les territoires
ultramarins vous comprenez ça tout à
fait et essayer évident de dire on ne
subit pas qu'une fille sanitaires ont
subi et on n'arrête pas de le dire aussi
une crise économique mais pour que
l'économie puisse redémarrer et être
luxuriantes
il faut que pour l'instant la population
ne soit pas trop touchée par une haie
passé dp mikovits donc il ya des
priorités à mettre en place la priorité
aujourd'hui c'est de limiter l'extension
de l'épidémie ce département de la
réunion et donc les musiques de
l'application des mesures barrières
l'application depuis ce matin de mai de
confinement devrait y contribuer et nous
permettre je l'espère passée cette
quatrième vague
merci patrick l'allemand d'avoir répondu
à nos questions je rappelle que vous
êtes colonel et médecin chef du 10 97 4